jornada histórica en colombia ha gustado
petro un ex guerrillero ya es presidente
y francia- márquez una lideresa
medioambiental afrodescendiente ya es
vicepresidenta después de que ganasen
las elecciones el pasado 19 de junio y
hoy ha sido en este 7 de agosto como
marcada tradición la jornada de toma de
posesión para ambos una jornada que ha
estado por primera vez cerca de la gente
ya que este tipo de ceremonias
normalmente otros presidentes la
celebraban solo con invitados se dice
que ha habido más de 100 mil personas
que durante todo el día han estado
también viendo actividades culturales
también desde nos comentaba un señor
llegó a las 6 de la mañana poder poder
sitio en la plaza de bolívar y
poder ver la ceremonia cargada de
símbolos ya que por ejemplo ha estado
presente en la espada de bolívar
llevando que el presidente saliente se
había negado a que estuviese presente
pero finalmente gustavo petro una vez le
han puesto la panda y ha sido proclamado
presidente su primera orden ha sido que
esa espada la traje sanz de la casa de
nariño del palacio de nariño a la
residencia del presidente y es que el
m-19 el grupo al que pretende perteneció
gustavo petro la robó en 1974 en su
discurso gustavo petro además ha estado
muy emocionado y ha recurrido a otras
cosas que ya había anunciado en campaña
o ya una vez elegido como presidente
electo y en su compromiso por lograr la
paz total en colombia pero también
lograr una transición energética u otras
cosas como por ejemplo un liderazgo en
latinoamérica que sea de unidad y sobre
todo ha mencionado que a partir de hoy
empieza la colombia de lo posible ya que
este es el primer gobierno de izquierda
de la historia en colombia